Say I've got a subspace V.
So V is some subspace,
maybe of Rn.
I'm going to define the
orthogonal complement of V,
let me write that
down, orthogonal
complement of V is the set.
And, this is shorthand notation
right here, would be
the orthogonal complement
of V.
So we write this little
orthogonal notation as a
superscript on V.
And you can pronounce this
as 'V perp', not for
'perpetrator' but for
'perpendicular.'
So V perp is equal to the set of
all x's, all the vectors x
that are a member of our Rn,
such that x dot V is equal to
0 for every vector V that is
a member of our subspace.
So we're essentially saying,
look, you have some subspace,
it's got a bunch of
vectors in it.
Now if I can find some other
set of vectors where every
member of that set is orthogonal
to every member of
the subspace in question, then
the set of those vectors is
called the orthogonal
complement of V.
And you write it this way,
V perp, right there.
So the first thing that we just
tend to do when we are
defining a space or defining
some set is to see, hey, is
this a subspace?
Is V perp, or the orthogonal
complement of
V, is this a subspace?
Well, you might remember from
many, many videos ago, that we
had just a couple of conditions
for a subspace.
That if-- let's say that a and b
are both a member of V perp,
then we have to wonder
whether a plus b is
a member of V perp.
That's our first condition.
It needs to be closed under
addition in order for this to
be a subspace.
And the next condition as well,
if a is a member of V
perp, is some scalar multiple of
a also a member of V perp?
And the last one, it has to
contain the zero vector.
Which is a little bit redundant
with this, because
if any scalar multiple of a is
a member of our orthogonal
complement of V, you could
just multiply it by 0.
So it would imply that the zero
vector is a member of V.
So what does this imply?
What is the fact that a and
b are members of V perp?
That means that a dot V, where
this V is any member of our
original subspace V, is equal
to 0 for any V that is a
member of our subspace V.
And it also means that b, since
b is also a member of V
perp, that V dot any member of
our subspace is also going to
be 0, or any b that
is a member of V.
So what happens if we
take a plus b dot V?
Let's do that.
So if I do a plus b dot
V, what is this
going to be equal to?
This is going to be equal
to a dot V plus b dot V.
And we just said, the fact that
both a and b are members
of our orthogonal complement
means that both of these
quantities are going
to be equal to 0.
So this is going to be
equal to 0 plus 0
which is equal to 0.
So a plus b is definitely a
member of our orthogonal
complement.
So we got our check box right
there I'll do it in a
different color than
the question mark.
Check, for the first
condition, for being a subspace.
Now is ca a member of V perp?
Well let's just take c.
If we take ca and dot it with
any member of our original
subspace this is the same thing
as c times a dot V.
And what is this equal to?
By definition a was a member of
our orthogonal complement,
so this is going to
be equal to 0.
So this is going to be c times
0, which is equal to 0.
So this is also a member
of our orthogonal
complement to V.
And of course, I can multiply
c times 0 and I
would get to 0.
Or you could just say, look, 0
is orthogonal to everything.
You take the zero vector, dot
it with anything, you're
going to get 0.
So the zero vector is always
going to be a member of any
orthogonal complement, because
it obviously is always going
to be true for this condition
right here.
So we know that V perp, or the
orthogonal complement of V, is
a subspace.
Which is nice because now we
can apply to it all of the
properties that we know
of subspaces.
Now the next question, and I
touched on this in the last
video, I said that if I have
some matrix A, and lets just
say it's an m by n matrix.
In the last video I said that
the row space of A is -- well,
let me write this way.
I wrote that the null space of
A is equal to the orthogonal
complement of the
row space of A.
And the way that we can write
the row space of A, this thing
right here, the row space of
A, is the same thing as the
column space of A transpose.
So one way you can rewrite this
sentence right here, is
that the null space of A is the
orthogonal complement of
the row space.
The row space is the column
space of the transpose matrix.
And the claim, which I have
not proven to you, is that
this is the orthogonal
complement of this.
This is equal to that, the
little perpendicular
superscript.
That's the claim, and at least
in the particular example that
I did in the last two videos
this was the case, where I
actually showed you that
2 by 3 matrix.
But let's see if this
applies generally.
So let me write my matrix
A like this.
So my matrix A, I can
write it as just a
bunch of row vectors.
But just to be consistent with
our notation, with vectors we
tend to associate as column
vectors, so to represent the
row vectors here I'm just
going to write them as
transpose vectors.
Because in our reality, vectors
will always be column
vectors, and row vectors are
just transposes of those.
r1 transpose, r2 transpose and
you go all the way down.
We have m rows.
So you're going to
get rm transpose.
Don't let the transpose
part confuse you.
I'm just saying that these
are row vectors.
I'm writing transposes there
just to say that, look these
are the transposes of
column vectors that
represent these rows.
But if it's helpful for you to
imagine them, just imagine
this is the first row of the
matrix, this is the second row
of that matrix, so
on and so forth.
Now, what is the null
space of A?
Well that's all of
the vectors here.
Let me do it like this.
The null space of A is all of
the vectors x that satisfy the
equation that this is going to
be equal to the zero vector.
Now to solve this equation,
what can we do?
We've seen this multiple
times.
This matrix-vector product is
essentially the same thing as
saying-- let me write it like
this-- it's going to be equal
to the zero vector in rm.
You're going to have m 0's all
the way down to the m'th 0.
So another way to write this
equation, you've seen it
before, is when you take the
matrix-vector product, you
essentially are taking
the dot product.
So to get to this entry right
here, this entry right here is
going to be this row dotted
with my vector x.
So this is r1, we're calling
this row vector r1 transpose.
This is the transpose of some
column vector that can
represent that row.
But that dot, dot my vector x,
this vector x is going to be
equal to that 0.
Now, if I take this guy-- let
me do it in a different
color-- if I take this guy and
I dot him with vector x, it's
going to be equal to that 0.
So r2 transpose dot x is
going to be equal to
that 0 right there.
So, another way to write this
equation is that r1 transpose
dot x is equal to 0, r2
transpose dot x is equal to 0,
all the way down to rn transpose
dot x is equal to 0.
And by definition the null space
of A is equal to all of
the x's that are members of--
well in this case it's an m by
n matrix, you're going to have
n columns-- so it's all the
x's that are members of rn, such
that Ax is equal to 0.
Or, you could alternately write
it this way: that if you
were to dot each of the rows
with x, you're going to be
equal to 0.
So you could write it
this way, such that
Ax is equal to 0.
That's an easier way
to write it.
So let's think about it.
If someone is a member, if
by definition I give
you some vector V.
If I were to tell you that
V is a member of the
null space of A.
Let's call it V1.
V1 is a member of
null space of A.
That means it satisfies this
equation right here.
That means A times
V is equal to 0.
A times V is equal to 0 means
that when you dot each of
these rows with V, you
get equal to 0.
Or another way of saying that
is that V1 is orthogonal to
all of these rows, to r1
transpose-- that's just the
first row-- r2 transpose, all
the way to rm transpose.
So this is orthogonal to all of
these guys, by definition,
any member of the null space.
Well, if you're orthogonal to
all of these members, all of
these rows in your matrix,
you're also orthogonal to any
linear combination of them.
You can imagine, let's say that
we have some vector that
is a linear combination of
these guys right here.
So let's say vector w is equal
to some linear combination of
these vectors right here.
I wrote them as transposes,
just
because they're row vectors.
But I can just write them as
regular column vectors, just
to show that w could be just
a regular column vector.
So let's say w is equal to c1
times r1, plus c2 times r2,
all the way to cm times rm.
That's what w is equal to.
So what happens when you take
V, which is a member of our
null space, and you
dot it with w?
So if you take V, and dot it
with w, it's going to be V
dotted with each of these guys,
because our dot product
has the distributive property.
So if you dot V with each of
these guys, it's going to be
equal to c1-- I'm just going
to take the scalar out-- c1
times V dot r1, plus c2 times V
dot r2-- this is an r right
here, not a V-- plus,
all the way to, plus
cm times V dot rm.
And we know, we already just
said, that V dot each of these
r's are going to
be equal to 0.
So all of these are going
to be equal to 0.
So this whole expression is
going to be equal to 0.
So if you have any vector that's
a linear combination of
these row vectors, if you dot
it with any member of your
null space, you're
going to get 0.
So let me write this way, what
is any vector that's any
linear combination
of these guys?
Well, that's the span
of these guys.
Or you could say that the row
space, that's the row space.
So if w is a member of the row
space, which you can just
represent as a column space of A
transpose, then we know that
V is a member of
our null space.
We know that V dot w is going
to be equal to 0, I just
showed that to you
right there.
So every member of our null
space is definitely orthogonal
to every member of
our row space.
So that's what we know so far.
Every member of null space of
A is orthogonal to every
member of the row space of A.
Now, that only gets
us halfway.
That still doesn't tell us that
this is equivalent to the
orthogonal complement
of the null space.
For example, there might be
members of our orthogonal
complement of the row space that
aren't a member of our
null space.
So let's say that I have
some other vector u.
Let's say that u is a member of
the orthogonal complement
of our row space.
I know the notation is a little
convoluted, maybe I
should write an r there.
But I want to really get set
into your mind that the row
space is just the column
space of the transpose.
Let's say that u is some member
of our orthogonal
complement.
What I want to do is show
you that u has to be
in your null space.
And when I show you that,
then we know.
So far we just said that, OK
then, everything in the null
space is orthogonal to the row
space, but we don't know that
everything that's orthogonal
to the row space, which is
represented by this set,
is also going to be
in your null space.
That's what we have to show, in
order for those two sets to
be equivalent, in order
for the null space
to be equal to this.
So if we know this is true, then
this means that u dot w,
where w is a member of our
row space, is going
to be equal to 0.
Let me write this down right
here, that is going to be
equal to 0.
And what does that mean?
That means that u is
also orthogonal.
So this implies that u dot--
well, r, j, any of the row
vectors-- is also equal to 0,
where j is equal to 1, through
all the way through m.
How do I know that?
Well, I'm saying that look, you
take u as a member of the
orthogonal complement of the row
space, so that means u is
orthogonal to any member
of your row space.
So in particular the basis
vectors of your row space-- we
don't know whether all of these
guys are basis vectors--
these guys are definitely all
members of the row space.
Some of them are actually the
basis for the row space.
So that means if you take u dot
any of these guys, it's
going to be equal to 0.
So if u dot any of these guys is
equal to 0, that means that
u dot r1 is 0, u dot r2 is equal
to 0, all the way to u
dot rm is equal to 0.
Well, if all of this is true,
that means that A times the
vector u is equal to 0.
That implies this, right?
You stick u there, you take
all the dot products, it's
going to satisfy
this equation.
Which implies that u is a member
of our null space.
So we've just shown you that
every member of your null
space is definitely a member of
the orthogonal complement.
And now we've said that every
member of our orthogonal
complement is a member
of our null space.
And actually I just noticed
that I made a
slight error here.
This dot product, I don't have
to write the transpose here,
because we've defined our dot
product as the dot product of
column vectors.
So this is the transpose
of some column vectors.
So you can un-transpose
it here and just
take the dot product.
Anyway, minor error there.
But that diverts me from my main
takeaway, my punch line,
the big picture.
We now showed you, any member of
our null space is a member
of the orthogonal complement.
So we just showed you, this
first statement here is
another way of saying, any
member of the null space-- or
that the null space is a subset
of the orthogonal
complement of the row space.
So that's our row space, and
that's the orthogonal
complement of our row space.
And here we just showed that any
member of the orthogonal
complement of our row space
is also a member
of your null space.
Well, if these two guys are
subsets of each other, they
must be equal to each other.
So we now know that the null
space of A is equal to the
orthogonal complement of the row
space of A or the column
space of A transpose.
Now, I related the null space
with the row space.
I could just as easily make a
bit of a substitution here.
Let's say that A is
equal to some
other matrix, B transpose.
Right?
It's going to be the transpose
of some matrix, you could
transpose either way.
So if I just make that
substitution
here, what do we get?
We get, the null space of B
transpose is equal to the
column space of B transpose,
right?
A transpose is B transpose
transposed.
Let me get my parentheses
right.
And then that thing's orthogonal
complement.
So what is this equal to?
The transpose of the transpose
is just equal to B.
So I can write it as, the null
space of B transpose is equal
to the orthogonal complement
of the column space of B.
So just like this, we just show
that the left-- B and A
are just arbitrary matrices.
So this showed us that the null
space, sometimes it's
nice to write in words,
is the orthogonal
complement of row space.
And this right here is showing
us, that the left null space
which is just the same thing as
a null space of a transpose
matrix, is equal to,
orthogonal-- I'll just
shorthand it-- complement
of the column space.
Which are two pretty
neat takeaways.
We saw a particular example of
it a couple of videos ago, and
now you see that it's true
for all matrices.